hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play stocked what
would you do if you wake up in a place
you have never seen before
find the key in escape [ __ ] hell I
loaded this up once because I didn't
realize the intro though so soon but I
got out of it I didn't play it at all do
not look and do not close your eyes for
too long
alright so this is actually made on an
engine that I've never heard of before
called the fire bowl engine but either
way it's a game called stock I think it
might have something to do with slender
but I'm not exactly sure huh hello
you seem to be dead good for you you win
the knob being a live broom ha what the
hell was that
hello ok starting off pretty quickly
here yeah I do not recognize the onion
but it looks pretty good so far don't
know what's with all the dead bodies
just saying seems kind of weird and
there seems to be a blank mechanic but
anyway what would you do if you woke up
in a place you've never been before
that's from haunts slender it's under
haunt whatever you want to call it okay
there are a lot of dead bodies here and
I don't know what that monster thing was
but it it didn't look friendly it's just
a pair of legs sitting up there ok
alright I feel it now I don't like this
place general sense of an easy hey buddy
[ __ ] you
ahh oh jesus crist oh man oh I'm playing
there's a couple oh crap there's a
couple difficulty settings those new pro
and nerd I was just assuming that nerd
was tougher than pro so I picked Pro
uh-huh oh man there's a good one I
wonder if this Mazda has any sort of
backstory you know like slender does
probably a little bit this is all a
specimen crates specimens or what I
think the blinking might be just a bit
too frequent seems it kinda it's kind of
jarring that it happened so often ok
another dead guy
it's getting quieter and I don't like
that okay I need to find a key sorta and
then get out of here here's kind of
doing a little dance there little jig
seem to be uneasy can I can jump ooh
maybe I could jump over this sting herb
yep nope that's not gonna happen ah do
not like that heartbeat barrels of blood
why why I even know where I am the
environment seems to be you know ah [ __ ]
you
Jesus get out of here you still there
oh wait I turned around what the hell is
you just popping up to be there I know
I'm not supposed to stare at him for Oh
whatever whatever whatever just carrying
on he's getting just getting gone give
this a good try and then I can go home I
am home in the game home I can go to a
party aw crap this would be the perfect
place for an ambush
haha please just let me just start
running normally because I have a
feeling that uh yeah I don't quite know
the mechanics of how he gets to show up
or if he chases me or what uh-huh I just
don't know kind of just seems to be
random at this point I mean like you
know well done on the atmosphere the
environment seems a little bit
repetitive in playing I mean it's just a
boxing sort of a channel with no sky or
ceiling Oh help me help you help me I
don't care about you okay when I said
that though rows were a bit repetitive I
didn't want rooms of blood that's not
what I was looking for when I said
things were a bit repetitive this is
going into the back end of where I was
on the other side of what sit face and
maybe oh hello wait what no I got
flipped over and okay what's with this
is anything besides creepy
nope nope just creepy yeah you're here
Europe Europe ma'am what the I don't
know what's going on with that one seems
to be kind of halfway in the wall
there's nothing here
I'm gonna die it's got it I keep getting
yeah it keeps flipping me around it's
not just me it's actually something's
messing with me was this what are these
things
I can I can get stuck on it I can't do
anything with it that doesn't seem to be
a clear direction on what I'm doing
obviously with most indie horror games
it's people make do with what they have
it's a lot harder to make a game than it
seems because a lot goes into like if
there aren't pre-made textures and
objects and environments you have to
create everything on your own and you
may be like thinking whatever Haley you
may be thinking like oh no it couldn't
take that long they're just simple boxes
and barrels but not actually if do it
then you have to make the textures
yourself and aha the key what do I do
with it
whoa hey stop doing that what do I do
with this key I didn't see a door
anywhere it's gonna pop out in front of
me in there okay I have the key what
does it mean ah dude was it mean no must
save my run now oh this opened up this
was a door Edison appreciate that oh we
might have added or top turning me
around I had a suspicion I thought about
a door Oh get me out of here get me out
off [ __ ] don't pop up on me don't do it
ah it's a [ __ ] box what is this [ __ ]
is wool this blue there's nothing here
it's just a box it's a box there's
nothing here nothing damn it okay go
look huh
don't mess with me man I don't even know
what to call you
Jethro Fairchild Mayweather I don't know
not good with coming up with names Oh
kind of reminds me of the rake in a
couple ways but you know no one really
has a good idea what the rake looks like
so that could be at the window Oh lovely
I missed the whole line of dead bodies
in various states of decomposition and
MAME did miss was this a bike helmet is
that is that a heart what's that what is
this what are you I don't know
I don't care maybe I can jump up and get
it huh no no no no okay what stop
flip-flopping me I'm going back to the
way I came maybe the door to get out was
like other games at the beginning come
on one shot there's [ __ ] yeah um no
wait yeah yeah
what was that if I'm like doing the
two-step shuffle as I'm running goodbye
toxic waste why why don't tell me that
this is just some radioactive horror in
a place of eternal darkness
seriously why it's unnaturally ducted is
that a ceiling or is that sky I can't
even tell Oh what is it bull
wah run aah
I'm running why why am i running why am
i screaming don't you scream above aah
[ __ ] yeah
god damn it Oh aah seizure-inducing
right there all right I'm gonna cut that
out for you guys
Oh God stop that stop that okay stop
stop stop stop
thank you okay so sorry about that I'll
cut that out so you didn't see it was
just flashing a bit too much so
hopefully it didn't hurt anyone I know
some people out there have you know
epilepsy and stuff they can deal with
that so I don't want them to be bothered
by that anyway so I'm pretty good I mean
it's really really rough around the
edges you could use a lot of Polish but
I mean in terms of other indie horror
games I've played it's not the worst not
by far it a great atmosphere I mean
really good atmosphere the heart
pounding was was kind of connected to
from the beginning but the blinking was
a bit too much so if the developers
watching this I think you might be a bit
too much and I mean what's the point of
the blinking anyway because the blink a
mechanic doesn't play into the game at
all I don't think as far as I could tell
an SCP containment breach the blinking
is very important because it serves a
precise function in in any other game
the blink you might just be distracting
I don't know just my opinion of it
textures you did what you could I've
never heard of this engine I fireball
was it yeah but I mean it looked fine it
looked like kind of like the FPS creator
that I've seen before but anyway good I
give it up in our town err some Java now
town I don't know I don't usually give
rating so I'm not a reviewer by any
means but good job a lot of potential
keep it up guy whoever did it links in
the description below to download it so
thank you all so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
oh good
oh seven years battle over you